un concept inédit au vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines ce samedi
17 novembre les pistes un français
élites ont affronté des routiers sur la
piste dans une série d'épreuves
organisées sur une soirée ça va se jouer
à la et je pense qu'on risque
d'avoir des surprises sur les épreuves
d'endurance mais les pistards ont bien
l'intention donc de relever le défi et
de se montrer à la hauteur des routiers
sur les épreuves d'endurance et même
chose sur les épreuves de sprint où dans
l'élimination donc l'aller les routiers
vont défier nos sprinteurs l'expérience
inscrits dans le challenge assurances
vélo a été réalisée devant plus de 3000
personnes
c'est une bonne chose parce que déjà il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'événements
populaires et festifs en france voilà
avec des coureurs de renom
c'est une belle soirée une belle épreuve
ont beaucoup de plaisir
on profite on est plusieurs plusieurs
coureurs à se retrouver ce un peu inédit
donc c'est assez bons et certains
cyclistes ont pu tester de nouvelles
disciplines dans la bonne humeur comme
sur cette course en tandem je peux dire
que j'ai pratiqué du keirin bon c'était
en tandem mais c'est des sensations
vraiment spécifique
une impression que le vélo ce corps d un
peu dans tous les sens à l'arrière et je
sais pas les avants au niveau du
pilotage mais en tout cas c'est extra de
pouvoir découvrir cette discipline
un nouveau gala pourraient être
organisées dans les prochains mois selon
les organisateurs avec de nouvelles
épreuves au programme